DIANE ATKINSON: Well, thanks for
coming in your lunch hour for--
I hope what I'm
going to say isn't
going to give you indigestion.
But let's see.
Well, I've written about
suffragettes in the past.
And I'd always concentrated
on what they did
in terms of their militancy.
Remember, these are the
women who fought for the vote
in a very insistent, outrageous,
provocative, direct action
kind of way.
So I talked about their
campaign, which really started
with shouting at meetings,
interrupting politicians,
went right through to burning
down churches and attacking
works of art over a period
of about eight years.
So it was very controversial
and deeply unpopular.
So I'd written about.
I'd also written about
how modern they were.
How they invented political
merchandising and marketing
and branding.
They branded their campaign
really beautifully.
And more about that in a moment.
They had a color scheme of
purple, white, and green.
And they branded
and merchandised
their slogan, "votes for women,"
in all sorts of different ways.
So I found that very kind
of sexy and exciting.
And then I got to
thinking about, well,
who were these amazing women?
I mean, what kind of
person would do that?
Would make that journey?
Would become a suffragette?
Because make no mistake,
it was the most unpopular
political campaign
of the 20th century.
It was a coming-out
moment for anybody
who said in terms
of conversation
or by wearing a badge that
they were suffragettes,
because they were so
detested and so loathed.
All they wanted was to vote,
but the sheer effrontery of them
not asking for it nicely, but
demanding it outrageously,
and noisily, and
cheekily, and violently,
was something that people
just couldn't stomach.
So I was interested in who they
were, where they came from,
what their biographies are,
what their backstories are,
what their prehistory is.
And I was interested
in their mums and dads,
and their siblings, their
brothers and sisters,
their neighbors,
and family groups.
Because you had to have
your family on your side
if this was going to work.
And your family had to be quite
extraordinary to back you,
because they're going
to get a lot of flak
from neighbors, and
colleagues, and family members
if you support your
daughter embarking
on this kind of campaign.
So I was really interested to
get kind of the backstories
on them.
Of course, the lucky
suffragettes, if you like,
who persist and have a
long suffragette career
are extremely fortunate.
They've got supportive husbands
and fathers, et cetera.
Some women found that their
fathers and families were not
going to support it.
You know, they had some
very tough choices.
They either sort of shut up and
stop it, or they leave home.
They're thrown out.
They're cast out.
They're disinherited.
They're disowned.
And many of them
had that experience.
Some marriages rocked and
ended, and some engagements
broken off.
Quite a lot of women involved
in the campaign lost their jobs.
And in one of their papers,
called "Votes for Women,"
there's a regular feature
where suffragettes
are writing in, asking in
the situations wanted column
in the classified ads
section, explaining
they need a job because they've
been dismissed from their post.
And you could be
dismissed for even
having a suffragette leaflet
on your desk, not even been
spotted smashing a window
or anything like that.
It was just the fact
that you were interested.
You'd been to a meeting
was enough to get
you dismissed with mostly
pretty disastrous results.
So I was fascinated in
the strength of character
and the strength
of a family unit
that condoned this
kind of behavior.
I was also interested
in diversity.
I was interested in
all kinds of women who
were getting involved in there.
So I did a lot of digging
away at that kind of story.
And I found some great
examples of diversity.
I was interested in it
being a regional-- looking
at the regions rather-- and
understanding how nationwide it
was, which it was.
They had branches all over
the country quite quickly--
in Scotland, in Ireland, in
Wales, and all over England.
So that was a measure of its
success and organization.
And they even had shops
selling their merchandise.
Suffragette shops selling
purple, white, and green
stuff all over the country.
So that, I thought,
was pretty sexy, too.
And I was interested
in working-class women
because they've been very much
marginalized in this story.
It was often said that
the suffragettes were just
middle-class hobbyists.
They weren't interested
in working-class women.
Nothing could be
further from the truth.
So lots of things
to go and look for
and to weave into this story.
Well, I have to talk about the
ladies on the screen, first
of all, by saying
these are undoubtedly
the stars of the campaign.
On the far left is
Sylvia Pankhurst,
who is an artist and designer.
She gives the WSPU, the
militant campaign, the look.
She designs exhibitions,
designs logos.
She is responsible for the
branded look of the WSPU.
Her sister is next to her,
in the next image along,
she has a first-class
degree in law.
But because she's a
woman, you couldn't
be a lawyer then, which was
irksome to say the least.
So she gave her great strategic
thinking and logic and planning
skills into the campaign.
And she was their
big thinker, really.
And Mrs. Pankhurst, the mother,
who got them all together
and founded the Women's
Social and Political
Union in her parlor in 1903,
great, charismatic woman.
She could fire up a room.
She could light up
a room very quickly.
All of them could, actually.
All the Pankhurst girls
were charismatics.
She's a tiny creature.
Her shoe size was two.
But she's like a cannonball
when she got going.
She's amazing.
And then, Annie Kenny, who is
a mill girl from Oldham who
joined the campaign
very early on.
She becomes a very senior
member of the campaign.
She's the poster girl
for the campaign.
And she can reach into
working-class communities
and recruit women in the way
that the Pankhurst couldn't
always.
So she's a big
part of the story.
And she was very
pretty and the subject
of many different
postcards, which
women collected at the time.
This is the context the
suffragettes were operating in.
Mom is a suffragette.
Is your wife a suffragette?
You know, domestic
chaos comes when
women are involved in
politics and want the vote.
How dare they?
There's hundreds of these flying
around, different designs.
Thousands of them being
sent around the country
at this time.
It's the golden age
of the postcard.
People kind of made
arrangements to see each other
with these postcards.
London had 12 postal
deliveries a day.
Those were the days.
And they're a bit
like tweets and texts.
You could make an
arrangement in the morning,
and you could confidently
expect your postcard
to be delivered and
meet your friends
in the afternoon for tea
or whatever in the evening.
So it was a brilliant
means of communication.
So civilization is going to
collapse if women get the vote.
And certainly,
domestic chaos reigns
whenever they're asking for it.
This is the first suffragette
postcard I ever bought.
I thought it was just so daft.
I liked it, actually.
Suffragettes have
never been kissed.
And this was to frighten
young girls from being
involved in the campaign.
Because, they said, this
is what happens when you
don't take your life seriously.
And if you're
involved in politics,
you're going to be so
unattractive to men,
you're never going to be kissed.
You're going to have a very
sad and unfulfilled life.
So the message is--
it's the sexual frustration
of an unfulfilled
life that's driving these
women into asking for the vote.
So there we have it.
An apocalyptic vision--
when women vote,
this is what's going to happen.
There's about 10 in this series,
which are fantastic, hilarious,
and daft, of course.
I love the idea of what
happens when women vote.
They have their friends around.
How dare they?
They smoke.
They have chocolate.
They just hang out and just
relax while their husbands are
in the kitchen getting
very red in the face
and coping very badly with a
boiling child, and the washing,
and the everything.
So the reversal of roles
here is a horrible prospect.
It's horrible.
It's a topsy-turvy world.
It's to be stopped
early in its tracks.
And we've got to make
sure this doesn't happen.
And when women vote, they're
going to ask men to marry them.
They're not going to
just sit around and wait,
hoping it's going to happen.
So they're going to kind
of take the initiative.
And that's going to
be horrible, too.
This is Annie Kenny dressed
up to lead a procession.
As I said, she could reach
into working-class communities
everywhere, all
over the country.
And these are the clothes
she wore when she worked
in the cotton mills of Oldham.
She was a half-timer
from the age of eight.
When she was 13, she
became a full-timer.
And these were her mill clothes.
She was wearing clogs with steel
tips, a skirt, and a shawl.
Another shawl has been
put over her head.
So you know, it's
a really powerful,
rather haunting image.
And it was very successful,
and thousands of copies
of this image were sold.
Suffragettes could
be really young.
They could be teenagers.
And this girl here
was 17 when she
started her suffragette career.
She worked in her dad's
shop in Westminster.
He had a kind of chemist shop.
And she got involved.
And with her father's
blessing, she got involved--
lucky girl.
But she did change her name
to spare his embarrassment.
She was born Jessie Spinks,
which is such a nice name.
And she'd call herself
Vera Wentworth.
And that's how she was known.
Her prison record knows
her as Vera Wentworth,
but her real name
was Jessie Spinks.
So you could be really young.
You could be in your 20s
and 30s, 40s and 50s.
And even feminists
in their 70s, who'd
fought all sorts of interesting
campaigns in the 19th century,
in their 70s and
early 80s were joining
the suffragette campaign,
adding their imprimatur
to this movement and marching
alongside the Pankhurst going
to Parliament to
talk to politicians.
To "talk" to politicians,
which is to insist on the vote.
It wasn't nothing
to do with talking.
It was demanding.
So across the age
spectrum, women
are getting involved
in this struggle
and adding their own special
and unique qualities to it.
I like this image
because it shows you
how the movement
is kind of bursting
out all over the country.
The map shows where they had
branches, committee rooms,
and shops.
It's a brilliantly
organized campaign.
Everything was like
a military maneuver.
They left nothing to chance.
They had lots of volunteers
to make this happen.
They paid their organizers
2 pounds a week,
which a lot of the
legwork was done
by unpaid volunteers from
all class backgrounds,
not just middle-class girls
with nothing else to do.
And it was well-resourced.
They had a great couple who
were the business managers,
if you like.
They provided a lot
of the seed money.
And they happened to be
generous, kind, noble,
intelligent.
A wonderful couple called
the Pethick Lawrences.
Fred was a barrister, so he
gave lots of legal advice.
And lots of his money was
used to bailout suffragettes
from custody until their
cases were heard at court.
So a lot of his
personal fortune was
going to support the campaign.
And Emmeline, his wife,
was the fundraiser.
She raised the equivalent of 3
million pounds in five years.
The woman could not
stop raising money.
She has dozens of ideas, which
are brilliant at filling up
what they called the
"war chest," which
was their campaign fund.
Annie was having so much fun
in the suffragette campaign,
her sister, Jessie,
has come to run
one of the London departments.
And here she is sitting
in front of the map here.
She's got a senior
position, too.
So much nicer than
working in a cotton
mill is to actually
come to London
and be part of
something really vibrant
and very, very exciting.
This was the marketing
and merchandising.
The colors featured
very prominently.
They start off quite small with
badges and rosettes and sashes.
But very quickly,
there's a vast amount
of merch available to those
women who want to buy it.
At the top end, if you
were really well-off,
you could have a purple,
white, and green car
upholstered and decorated
with suffragette logos.
So that's high-end marketing.
You could get
suffragette bicycles.
You could get votes for women
cigarettes, and chocolates,
and marmalade, and all
kinds of foodstuffs.
You could get jewelry.
You could get dresses.
You could get slippers and
shoes and hats decorated.
I mean, whatever you
wanted, somebody out
there would make it for you.
And all the big
department stores
in London and the
major cities would
stock purple, white, and
green clothing and accessories
for suffragette customers.
There's a tea set there that
was on the market in 1909.
And there are
still a few around,
but they're extremely
rare and very expensive.
Well, suffragette campaign was--
I haven't got time to go
into too many of the kind
of year-on-year details.
But initially, from moving away
from interrupting meetings,
women were banned from
political meetings
because you never know.
They look quite nice, but
they could be suffragettes.
They could be so
troublesome, they
would just get up
and unfurl a banner
and shout votes for women
and interrupt politicians
making speeches.
So women were banned.
And to protest
that, they would get
onto the roofs of
those buildings
where they were banned, and
they would have banners.
And they'd do rooftop
protests, like prison protests.
They started it, really.
And when the police and the
firemen would try and hose them
down off the roof--
extremely dangerous--
the suffragettes got
so cross, they just
ripped the slates off the roof
and just chucked them down
on the police below.
So you know, these protests
could end up extremely
violent and dangerous.
And of course, it all adds
to their bad reputation.
They stalked
politicians as well.
They would follow them around
and just make their lives
a total misery.
They would follow
them into church.
And they would button hold
them and grab hold of them
and say, when are you going
to give women the vote?
They would follow them when
they were playing golf.
They'd hide in the
bushes and jump around
and say, when are you going
to give women the vote?
They were really
an absolute pain.
That was kind of slapstick
and funny and not so bad.
But then, when the government
promises to seriously consider
a bill and give it
time in Parliament
and allow it to become
law, when they renege
on these promises
three years running,
things start to get
really difficult.
And the suffragettes think, OK,
we're going to move on a bit.
We're going to move the action
a bit further down the line.
And it's extraordinary for
me to be saying these things,
because these were
just straightforward,
ordinary women.
All they wanted was
the vote, but they
found themselves caught up in
this most extraordinary battle
between the police, the
government, prison authorities,
and sometimes, members of
the public would attack them.
It was a really dangerous thing
to be to be a suffragette.
This one particularly dark
day in 1910, suffragettes
were waiting to hear
about a bill that was
being debated in Parliament.
Just waiting to hear when the
legal timetable was going to be
drawn up for it to become law.
Asquith, who is
the Prime Minister,
just completely torpedoes it.
And says, oh, no, well, we
haven't got time for that.
We'll think about
it again next year.
And this is after a lot
of peaceful lobbying
and campaigning.
So they set off in groups
of a dozen from Caxton Hall
where they were
meeting and waiting.
And they try and
get into Parliament.
And the police are
ready for them.
They know they're going to
kind of make their protest
in Parliament Square.
And Winston Churchill
was the home secretary.
Actually, recruited
a lot of policemen
from the East End who are used
to dealing with violent thugs.
And they were there
but in plain clothes.
They just looked like members
of the crowds, members
of the public.
And they were in disguise
really, in two ways.
They were wearing badges, which
said Men's League for Women's
Suffrage.
So they were pretending
they were supporters.
They weren't.
And they and the uniformed
police, like you can see here,
and mounted policemen,
actually their mission
was to handle that
situation in such a way
the women would never come
back and protest again,
which meant that women were
crushed against the railings
by police horses.
They were punched, kicked,
beaten, hair pulled,
clothes turned--
pulled off, really,
badly assaulted.
And about 40 women were taken
down various side streets
around Parliament Square
and sexually assaulted
by uniformed policemen and
these agent provocateur.
And the crowd were
encouraged to join in.
So it's a terrible day.
150 women are involved in
these kind of assault, physical
and sexual assault.
Caxton Hall, where
they'd been meeting,
becomes like a field hospital.
Nurses with suffragettes
sympathies rushed there.
And doctors rushed there to
do some very basic first aid.
But it was an awful day.
And it triggered riots
the following weeks,
where hundreds of women
are being arrested.
Some of them are being
discharged, but a lot of them
are going to prison.
Holloway fills up.
And the others are just
bussed around the country
because there's no
room in Holloway.
They've got to go to Liverpool,
Bristol, Newcastle, Manchester,
anywhere, just to kind of-- to
cope with them while they're
going to be charged
and their sentences
are going to be handed down.
It's such a difficult day.
It's such a dangerous,
horrible moment.
And Mrs. Pankhurst said, I
don't think we can do this.
We can't go to
Parliament like this
because it gives police
too much time to molest,
manhandle, all sorts
of things are going on.
So what we need to do is we
need to have protests where
women are arrested immediately.
So that's going to be like
guerrilla campaigning.
And she said, we're going to
have to wage guerrilla warfare
on this government because
we cannot trust the police
to police these
demonstrations properly.
The campaign goes underground
in the autumn of 1910.
And violence and
vandalism breaks out all
over the country.
And the idea is--
smashing windows, yes.
They stood there and
waited to be arrested
because that would
mean they went straight
to the police station.
There's none of this pushing
and shoving and kettling,
which still happens
at demonstrations.
It's kind of a quick protest.
They're going to go to prison.
I mean, they don't
want to go to prison,
but they don't mind
doing that if this
is going to further the cause.
So this is a tipping point.
And this day, the
18th of November,
1910, is remembered ever after
by suffragettes for the rest
of their lives as Black Friday.
People sometimes
say to me, who's
your favorite suffragette?
And I say, well, there's
about 200 of them,
and they're in this book.
But to pick one, I have to
pick Edith Rigby, because she
was just so gorgeous, and
outrageous, and unconventional.
She was a doctor's doctor and
a doctor's wife in Preston.
And she was absolutely
single-minded in getting
the vote and focusing
on working-class women.
She comes from a nice,
comfortable middle-class
background, but her interests
lie in votes for working women.
And she recruits local women.
She takes them down to London.
They get involved in all kind
of protests and demonstrations.
And you just had to
take one look at Edith
to know how
unconventional she was.
She didn't wear the normal
clothes an Edwardian lady--
corsets and pretty dresses
and that kind of stuff.
She wore clothes that
she made herself.
I suppose we think of her now
perhaps as the first hippie
because they're really
big, baggy dresses, kind
of homemade dresses.
She made her own jewelry.
And that's all a bit bohemian
and pretty, but very weird
for the times.
Nobody else was
dressed like that.
And she wore sandals
all year-round.
People thought that was weird.
And she chain-smoked
all the time.
And that was most unladylike.
So that's what Edith was like.
And she does the whole
suffragette number.
She goes to Parliament.
She protests.
She breaks windows.
She burns down houses.
I just want to point
out that whenever
suffragettes burned down a
house, it was always empty.
They always looked
at the place first.
Their owners were
still unhappy about it,
but no human life was lost.
So for the last
few months of 1913,
Edith's on the run
from the police.
Even her husband
doesn't know where
she is because she's
got out of prison.
Because she's been
on hunger strike,
and she's been force-fed.
And she was released
on a special license.
And she hides in
Ireland, in Galway.
And she's there not
communicating with her husband
or friends at all.
And just waiting to slip
back into the country,
to carry on doing
more militancy.
So Edith Rigby is a
really interesting woman.
And I mean, there are
200 women in this book
with incredible stories.
They do things that I don't
think many of us or any of us
would be able to do now.
It required a really
particular mindset
and phenomenal
sacrifice and courage.
I like this photograph because
it looks really modern.
It was taken by
a special branch.
It's a surveillance photograph.
There was a man hiding in
a van in the exercise yard
or in a box in the exercise
yard at Holloway Prison.
And he's taken a picture.
She's got no idea she's
being photographed.
Multiple copies of
these prints will
be sent all over the
country to police stations
to look out for women,
because they were very mobile.
They would arrive in places
with aliases and in disguise.
They moved all over the country.
They were like soldiers,
really, in a campaign.
They would turn up.
And they would smash windows.
And they would put phosphorous
bombs in pillow boxes.
And they would vandalize
sports facilities.
They would get ashed in
burning golf greens--
golf, that kind of stuff.
They were a tremendous
problem to the police.
And special branch had lots
of detectives following them
and taking photographs
of them to try and get
a handle on who they were,
and where they were going,
and what to do when
they turned up.
Grace's father was a
clergyman in Norfolk.
And he knew what she was up to.
He didn't try and stop her.
But to make life a
bit easier for him,
they have a very
distinctive surname.
They're called Marcon.
She's called Grace Marcon.
So she had an alias.
Quite a lot of
suffragettes had an alias
to spare their
fathers' feelings,
even though they knew
they were suffragettes.
And she called
herself Frida Thomas.
And she has an
interesting career.
In London, she works
as a gymnastics teacher
and a masseuse.
But when she's on
suffragette missions,
she's obviously
not able to work.
And she's kind of on
the run from the police
a lot of the time.
So Grace Marcon is a
tremendous character.
And she was about 20 when she
got involved in this campaign.
Well, being a
suffragette was hard.
If you tried to make a
speech outside, perhaps
in Wimbledon Common
or wherever, the crowd
could be really hostile.
They could be very abusive.
They could be very vulgar.
It's mostly male,
rough crowds who
are kind of following you
around to just bait you, really.
They would perhaps throw
rotting fruit and vegetables,
lumps of coal, cabbages, rocks.
Suffragettes were often stoned.
Sylvia had experiences
in the East End
where dead cats and
dogs were thrown at her.
So it was horrible
and dangerous.
And again, it's hard to
imagine doing that now in front
of a really rough crowd.
Of course in those days, it
was even more unimaginable.
So there's a lot of that.
There's all the stuff
that's going on in prison,
which is being force-fed.
The reason why they
go on hunger strike
is they say we're
political prisoners.
We're being treated
as common criminals.
What's happening?
Men who are
campaigning politically
and are being arrested
for political crimes
in their campaigning methods
are given special status.
Right back to the 19th
century that was then.
Why aren't we being
given this status?
And the government would
never give in on that.
So they went on hunger strike.
And hundreds of women
were fed by force.
The worst-- there are
three ways of doing it.
I'll just go straight
to the worst, which
was where liquid food
is poured in a funnel
down a tube, which is
pushed down your throat,
down here to the
top of the stomach.
So it's just poured
straight into your stomach.
It's milk with raw egg,
or it's milk with brandy,
or ether extract,
that kind of thing.
And you're tipped
back in your chair.
You're held down
by four wardessess,
and that's poured into you.
Imagine-- the gag reflex
would not be happy about this.
And suffragettes had their vocal
chords damaged, had their teeth
knocked out in the struggle.
While it's being poured in,
they're vomiting it straight
back out again.
Sometimes, food
got into the lungs.
And they had pleurisy
and pneumonia.
So it's really dangerous,
because with pneumonia, this
is before antibiotics.
And so you could
die from pneumonia.
And a lot of people did.
So it's torture.
You know, it's torture
by no other name.
But hundreds of
them were doing it.
It's their decision.
Nobody told them to do it.
And their position is we're
going to force the government
to give us the vote.
So the stories of hunger
striking and force feeding
are really powerful
recruiting tools
to women who will
hear these stories.
And they're going to
have a response to that.
They might not want to
go out and do militancy,
but they're going
to give some money.
They're going to give some time.
They're going to be
involved in the campaign.
And you know, these stories--
these moments were
really important
because it galvanized women
to support the suffragettes.
They might not like militancy.
They might not
really approve of it,
but they felt it was
a means to an end,
a means to a very,
very important end.
So there's a lot of scary
stuff, dangerous stuff,
unpopular stuff you've got to
kind of develop a thick skin
about, but there's fun as well.
They're very big on parties.
They're very big
on tea and cakes.
That was a big part of the
kind of recruiting process.
And here, they're having
a suffragette sleepover.
This is when it's census night,
when the government's sent
around to count the population.
Suffragettes said, we pay taxes.
We have no voice in
the making of laws,
so we're not going
to be counted.
The government
threatened to fine them
and sent them to prison.
Didn't matter.
And 4,000 women
dodged the census.
They had a party wherever
they went on the night.
They gathered groups together.
They hired caravans and
went out on Wimbledon Common
and spent the night out
there and had a party.
They had smoking parties.
They went roller
skating all night.
It was a lot of fun.
And making it a really
important political point.
No voice in our
legislation, so we're
not going to be part of
your official headcount.
So I like this because
it looks like it was fun.
I was very lucky to meet
this lady in the 1990s
when I worked at
Museum of London.
There she is as a
young suffragette.
She's called Victoria Simmons.
In that photograph,
she's about 19.
She came up to London, and
she broke windows in Whitehall
in 1912.
She went to prison
for two months,
and she went on hunger
strike, and she was force-fed.
She came up with
her sister, Winnie.
Winnie managed to get away,
so Winnie went and sang songs
every day outside
Holloway Prison
to keep Victoria
kind of company.
And when Victoria
went back to Clifton,
which is where she came
from, her local clergyman,
the man whose
church she attended,
saw her selling a
newspaper in the street.
And he was so disgusted by
the fact she'd been to London,
and she did what
she did, he just
spat in her face,
which is not what
you'd expect a clergyman to do.
But people felt able to
make those kind of remarks
and those kind of behaviors.
I met her in the
1990s, when she's 100.
She's 100 in that photograph.
And she was still a
suffragette, actually.
She still had that
suffragette twinkle.
fire in her eyes.
And she'd been a political
campaigner all her life.
She'd got married.
She was the first
woman optician.
She got involved in all kinds
of animal rights campaigns.
In her last campaign for the
audition of women priests,
she lived to see that happen.
And it was great.
The very first time I met her--
well, the only time I met
her, but I spent a whole day
with her, and it was such
a thrill to actually meet
someone who had done it.
I could see completely how
she had taken that position.
I said, well, let's go and
have some lunch, shall we?
She was perfectly able.
She didn't need a walking
frame or anything.
She's perfectly fine living
in a flat on her own.
And she said, well, it will
have to be vegetarian, dear.
Because I've been a
vegetarian since 1897.
So you know, that's how she was.
And I said, what's
it like living here
in Brighton-- in Hove?
She said, oh, it's
all very well.
But it's full of old people.
I think she thought she
was about 50, actually.
She didn't realize she was 100.
So it was really
nice to meet her
and to just kind
of spend some time
with somebody who had actually
been and done the business.
And the last photograph I want
to talk about is this one here.
And this is-- was taken in 1967.
And these are the
moderate campaigners
and the militant campaigners.
They've been bought
together for a photo shoot.
"The Observer" have
gathered 13 of them.
They can get together
on a particular day
for a big feature that
was in "The Observer."
And I love this photograph.
I just love it because
it's so colorful.
It's so vibrant.
And it's about the personality.
I think the color
of their clothes
reflect the vibrancy
of those characters.
And I just want to point out a
few of my favorites, actually.
I'm just going to
move over here.
Now, this is like the
formal photograph.
It's all kind of--
everything's OK here.
But things have relaxed
a bit by the time
we get to this photograph.
[INAUDIBLE] burning
down buildings.
When she's interviewed years
later, her eyes lit up.
She was really excited talking
about when she burnt down
these buildings.
So she's in and out of prison.
She's on hunger strike.
She's force-fed.
She was somebody who had
food go into her lungs.
She had pleurisy and
pneumonia at the same time.
She could have died.
She was only 20 when
it happened to her.
When she was charged
in court at Bow Street,
the magistrate sort of sent
her down for six months.
She said, oh,
well, I'll be back.
Next time I'm out, I'm going to
burn down two buildings a week.
That's my project.
She was completely
kind of irrepressible.
And because she
was so small, she
could be smuggled out
in laundry baskets.
And what they often did was they
were out on special licenses.
They're supposed to sit in this
place, this designated address,
to get better, to
put on some weight,
and just wait to be rearrested.
That was the scheme.
That was a police idea.
Well, they're not going
to do that, are they?
They're going to kind
of recover a bit.
They're going to put
on a bit of weight,
just be looked after in
a nursing home context.
And then they're
going to get out.
They're not going to
wait to go back to prison
and carry on the
whole business again.
So they would
arrange for parties
if women would come
to see them, see
how they're getting on-- flowers
and chocolates, all that.
And there'd be a body
double amongst that group.
So a number of
times, she got out
by swapping clothes
with somebody--
a young, small person.
And she would just
walk past the police
who were on 24-hour guard
outside the premises
where she's being looked after.
So very often, she just
walked straight past them.
Or she goes out in
a laundry basket.
And she had this
brilliant ability.
Because she's so small,
actually, she can be a child.
She's often dressed as a boy.
And that's how she gets
away from the police.
So she had lots of-- she
had a very lengthy record,
but she hardly spent
any time in prison
because she's so
good at getting away.
I love her.
And this is Mrs. Gwen O'Brien.
Gwen O'Brien was one of
Mrs. Pankhurst's bodyguards
because there's
about 40 women who
were part of the
bodyguard who used
to mob her to try and stop her
being arrested by the police.
So Gwen had many
fisticuffs with the police
to trying stop Mrs.
Pankhurst being arrested.
And the last lady I want to
talk about is this one here.
She's called Una Duval.
Una Duval was-- again,
total career suffragette.
She got mired in 1912.
And she made a press release
before she got married
and said, I shan't be
saying the words "I obey"
in the wedding service.
And everybody got completely
agitated about this.
The Archbishop of
Canterbury said, well,
you won't be married if
you don't say "I obey."
She said, well, I'm
not going to say it.
So she carried on.
She got married.
She completely kind of ignored
the Archbishop of Canterbury.
And she just went ahead with it.
But that gives you a clue as
to how strong-minded they were,
how dedicated they were,
how visionary they were,
and how insistent and persistent
they were in their views.
And she was part of
a suffragette family.
She married into a family
called the Duval family.
So the Dugdales
and Duvals numbered
about six female suffragettes
and two husband supporters.
Now, they couldn't
join the WSPU,
but husbands were really
important in protecting
their wives, their female
relatives and friends,
from attacks from any
different direction.
And so this important family,
the Dugdales and Duvals
were part of this whole
family of suffrage.
I think all the women who
got involved in suffrage
thought they were
part of a family.
And you really needed
to feel that to actually
be able to keep doing
it, because it was hard.
It involved a lot of sacrifice
and quite a lot of suffering.
That's all I want to
say about the images.
I'm very happy to take
questions if you--
I'll try and answer them.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
was you've obviously
been talking about
this and researching
this for a very long time.
And in the time you've been
doing so, and more recently,
have you found the
conversation has changed?
Have your audiences changed
to be more receptive, more
understanding?
DIANE ATKINSON: Yes.
I mean, I've been
involved with this subject
for a long, long time.
And for years, there
was no love in the room
for the suffragettes.
People couldn't stand them.
Even academics, even historians
were quite dismissive of them.
They believed the
lie that it was just
middle-class women looking
after their own interests.
But now, there's
quite a lot of love
in lots of rooms where I
talk about the suffragettes.
Because people can hear,
really, the full story and
understand about
their characters,
and their strengths, and their
courage, and their commitment.
And I think they're women that
lots of people can be proud of.
But the mood and
the attitude has
shift as the full story
of their involvement
and their struggle
actually emerges.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I've got a question.
So I kind of feel right now
with the "Me Too" trend,
I feel that we
are perhaps living
through another pivotal moment
as we did a hundred years ago
with the suffragettes.
I don't know if you
would agree with that?
And my question to
you is, do you feel--
I mean, I guess I've
got two questions.
One, I wonder whether
these ladies would
feel proud of where we are
right now as a society,
or whether they
think it actually
hasn't moved on enough?
Because I personally feel
we're still quite far
from true gender equality.
And my second question to you
is with this pivotal moment
that we're living through
now, with the "Me Too" trend,
do you feel this will result in
a significant move towards kind
of genuine gender equality and
the kind of world, I guess,
these ladies hoped
they would achieve?
DIANE ATKINSON: Well,
I mean, excuse me.
That's two good questions.
I think that the suffragettes
thought a lot of this
would have been
sorted out by now.
I think one of their
wishes was for equal pay.
They were talking
about equal pay
at the turn of the
century and before.
So they'd be very disappointed
about the inequity
of unequal pay.
And they would say,
I'm sure, how did you
let this go on for so long?
Don't forget, in 1970, the
Equal Pay Act was passed.
It was supposed to be right
across the board, fully
implemented by 1975.
And it still hasn't happened.
So they'd think that
was weird, which I think
is code for shockingly bad.
I think the "Me Too" moment
is going to actually--
I think both of these issues are
going to result in something.
Because I think so many
people are affected by it.
It can't just be papered over.
It can't be ignored.
It can't be brushed
under the carpet.
So many people have the
issue of unequal pay
and sexual harassment.
I can't see that
nothing can happen.
But I think what we do--
and the suffragettes
would say, well, how did we
let this go on for so long?
Because the suffragettes
were campaigning for the vote
to stop sexual harassment.
And they said, well, you
haven't got that yet.
I think they would
like us to have
Mrs. Pankhurst's slogan
at the top of our minds,
"deeds not words."
Stop talking about it.
Stop having committee
meetings about it.
Just talk about it
but make a strategy
as to how it's going to happen.
What are we going
to do about it?
How are we going to bring this?
How can we deliver
these changes?
Because talking about
it just isn't enough.
And Mrs. Pankhurst
would really love
us to revive her slogan,
"deeds not words."
And I think we perhaps
ought to think about that.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, Alice.
I suppose along the
"deeds not words" action,
you talked about essentially
Asquith going back
on his promises.
Says, yes, we'll do
it, and then not.
And then, the
suffragettes feeling
that they had to escalate
the types of actions.
To what extent do you
think that actually
if you want real change,
that extreme actions actually
take you to a place that
dialog just can't do.
Is it something-- real change,
can it be achieved with dialog?
Or do you in a
democracy actually need
to demonstrate your
frustration, anger in more
sort of vocal extreme manners?
DIANE ATKINSON: I don't
know if I've been taken over
by a suffragette spirit.
It's possible that I have.
But I don't think
dialog's enough.
I think extreme action,
whatever that is.
Whether it's a general
strike, women going on strike
and not doing any work at all.
I don't know.
But it's got to be strong.
Just talk is so easy.
It's so cheap.
How do you translate
that into something?
Although governments never
want to agree or concede,
they always give in to violence
and extremism eventually.
They just have to manage
that really carefully.
But they will always have
to make some concessions,
because you can't have
the country at war.
It just can't go on.
So I think the suffragettes were
right to pursue this campaign.
They suffered enormously
because of it.
But in the end, the net result
of it was during the war
when they realized
that a lot of soldiers
had accidentally lost
the right to vote
because they were away from
home and hadn't re-registered.
It's just a technical thing.
Once they realized
that had happened,
they had to quickly
re-enfranchise,
because this is a PR nightmare.
They then decided, well,
all these men are fighting.
We've got a large number of
men who haven't got the vote.
We got to enfranchise them
because they are putting
their lives-- laying
their lives down
for our country and our empire.
So soldiers are re-enfranchised.
21-year-old men
are re-enfranchised
across the board.
There's also like,
how are we going
to reward women for war work?
Because war work done
by women was critical.
The home front, that war
was fought and won by women.
So they had to make some
kind of remark about that.
And that meant that women
over 30 with certain property
qualifications got the vote.
And I really feel that if
the suffragette hadn't pushed
the struggle to the
top of the agenda,
that wouldn't have happened.
The thought of another
suffragette campaign
starting up again, if they
didn't give them the vote,
we just couldn't face it.
There's so much should be done
once the war was over that
dealing with that as well.
And also, the
suffragettes would be
so re-invigorated by the moral
high ground of saying, hang on.
What more do women have
to do to get the vote?
We fought the war.
The men have been at the front,
and we fought the war at home.
So I think the suffragettes
created a mood whereby
women had to get the vote.
I mean, it was unfortunate that
they weren't all enfranchised
on equal age thing.
But if they had
been, women would
have been in the majority.
Politically, just
couldn't be contemplated.
We think now, well, why not?
But at that time going
from like no votes of women
to having women in the
majority in the electorate,
that was just scary.
And it just very unappetizing.
So I think the extremism of the
suffragettes actually counted
for something when it
came to the Representation
of the People Act.
And that's how
women got the vote.
Sorry it was a
long-winded answer,
but it's quite a
complex question.
SPEAKER 1: Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Thank you so much for joining.
Where did your personal interest
in this topic come from?
DIANE ATKINSON: I worked
at the Museum of London,
and they have this
really important
world-class collection called
the Suffragette Fellowship
Collection.
And it's such a touching story.
Because when the vote
was won in the 1920s,
I always imagined what
they did with themselves
after that really exciting
campaign and the war period
because they were all involved
in all kinds of war work.
And now I know what they did.
They collected stuff to
remember the campaign.
They had this fellowship
to remember the Pankhurst
and to remember militancy.
And they gathered all
the banners, and posters,
and stuff.
And they made this huge archive.
They had a little
museum in Cromwell Road.
And you could just go along
and kind of look at banners.
And it was like a
very amateurish thing,
but it was a collection
that was growing
and growing and growing.
People were donating
their hunger strike
medals, their jewelry--
everything.
And we had this at
the Museum of London.
I used to just go and spend
hours Kind of messing around
in there.
And looking at stuff, and
picking out photographs,
and just learning about them.
Finding names to put
to these photographs.
And so I kind of
immersed myself in that.
And I started getting the
compulsion to write about them
and just to work out
what the stories were.
And I curated an
exhibition in 1992
called Purple, White,
and Green, which
talked about the marketing.
It was the foreground of the
campaign-- of my exhibition.
The backdrop was
really militancy.
And I just kept with it.
I had a break from
writing about them.
I did other
biographies of women.
And I kind of came back to
them thinking, yeah, right.
OK, let's get
biographical with this lot
and find out how
this all came about.
So my book is a collective
biography of 200 suffragettes.
I think I am possessed by them.
Because every day,
I think about them.
I kind of think, oh, I
wonder what Edith Rigby would
have done about that.
What would Edith have done?
So no, they're really inspiring.
They're amazing.
I love them.
AUDIENCE: In the last
couple of elections
we've seen the Women's Equality
Party come to more prominence
at least than before.
What's your take
on that movement?
And is that just a
modern embodiment
of the suffragette spirit, or
is it maybe a pale imitation?
What would the
suffragettes do in
the current political climate?
DIANE ATKINSON: Well, I
think the suffragettes would
say we should have had
the Women's Equality
party a long time ago.
I think they'd support them.
I think they would endorse
a lot of their policies.
I think they'd like
what they're doing.
They'd approve of it, certainly.
And I think they'd want
us all to vote for them.
And I think lots of people
say to me, what should I do?
I did an event at WOW at the
Royal Festival on Saturday--
Women of the World.
And a young woman said to
me, what can I do about this?
I said, well, join the
Women's Equality Party.
And sadly, she said,
I've never heard of them.
So my mission would
be-- my advice
to women's equality-- get
out there and get known more.
Get some candidates,
get some money,
and try and think
about adopting some
of these suffragette tactics.
Because I think that's what
lots of women want and need.
AUDIENCE: Before you started,
we talked about technology
and the impact that can have.
And one of the themes
that you brought up
was how organized the
suffragettes were.
Do you think that technology is
possibly hindering the ability
to get out a consistent,
organized message to achieve
an individual goal?
For example, Women's
Equality Party.
Are there too many voices asking
for too many different things?
DIANE ATKINSON: Yes.
I think one of the virtues
of the suffragettes
was that they were very clear.
There weren't democratic.
They weren't interested
in committees.
They made policy and they
wanted their supporters
to follow the policy.
And it's quite
straightforward in a way,
because I often think one way of
making sure things don't happen
is to have a committee
because it just takes so long.
It becomes a talking shot.
I'm sorry, but it just
is so frustrating.
It just ends up being all
about the committee, not about
the project and the goal.
So I think they need
to have a single issue
or a big, identifiable message.
And to push that.
Because that will bring
so many people together.
One of the reasons why the
suffragette campaign was
so diverse and so huge
really, is the fact
they're going for the vote.
The vote, the vote, the vote.
And that brings a lot of
people to that campaign.
And very importantly,
great diverse talent.
And it's talent that
has so many impacts.
It reaches into so many
aspects of the organization.
So I think a
single-issue campaign
is something that really
has a chance of success
because you've got numbers.
You've got diversity.
And that's where I think results
can be gained more quickly.
By the way, I think
the suffragettes
would have loved social media.
They would have loved
tweeting and Instagram.
They would have loved that.
They would have
really embraced that.
They took the technology that
was available at the time
to the max.
And they really worked on that.
So they'd think, hey,
you've got Twitter.
You've got all this stuff.
What's happened?
AUDIENCE: I've got
one last question.
So I haven't read the book yet.
Looking forward to reading it.
You mentioned 200 women?
DIANE ATKINSON: 200
suffragettes, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I was wondering, are
there any prominent male,
can we say suffragettes?
DIANE ATKINSON: Well, yeah.
They couldn't--
well, I call them--
AUDIENCE: That you came across.
DIANE ATKINSON: Yeah.
No, there's some good guys.
There are lots of good guys.
Edith Rigby's husband
was a doctor, Charlie.
And he was just like
the ideal husband.
He just let her get on with it.
He never stopped her.
He was worried about hunger
striking being a doctor,
but he didn't ever
try and stop her.
And a lot of the time when
she was just in Ireland,
he had no idea where she was.
And a family friend
wrote and said,
oh, I'm so sorry about Edith.
This is all very trying
for you, isn't it?
He said, I don't
want your sympathy.
I don't need it because I back
Edith in everything she does.
She has the courage of a lion.
And I don't have the moral
courage that she has.
So I will back her,
whatever she does.
Now, that's quite an admission
for a man at that time to make.
So there are lots of good
men like Charlie Rigby.
But they suffered.
Their reputations
amongst other men.
Men thought they were,
like men in dresses.
They said they were unsexed.
They were sex traitors.
So some of their
careers suffered.
Their reputations suffered.
Their friendships were broken.
But there are some good
men in that book, too.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much.
And I think a lot
of us are really
excited to read the book.
Thank you very much for coming.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much.
[APPLAUSE]